what do you think Elon hero or villain
the internet's pretty split halfway at
the moment the idea that like he could
figure out spaceships and not Twitter
like Twitter isn't like a hard thing
like have you ever met someone in Tech
like they're not the best like
socializing human beings do you know
what I mean like it the fact that they
could figure out socializing like have
you seen them talk to each other like
Zuckerberg has to like be reminded to
Blink right like his eyes dry out he's
like oh I like MMA I like surfing blink
okay there you go right it's like so so
it's like there's there's these aren't
the people that are good at socializing
and they figured out apps around
socializing
Elon can figure out how to just write
something and post it it's not that
difficult
so if I have no question he's going to
figure out it's going to be better
they'll have a billion users they'll
find out a way to monetize it it'll be
easy but is he doing it for the right
reasons in your opinion
yeah because that's the question right I
don't know but in my opinion yeah I
think I I would agree like it's well
what's the right reasons I have I might
have a different right reason than you
for me it would be to if he cares about
Free Speech it would be to open up
Communication online yes that's my
opinion I think that's part of it but I
think that there's other parts what are
the bones I think if you're a
billionaire you need in some sort of
like news apparatus to protect yourself
like there's a reason why Microsoft Bill
Gates got MSNBC the MS is Microsoft NBC
right Amazon got the Washington Post
it's like once you get enough money
where people should kill you because you
have that much money you need a
newspaper or something to be like yo
don't kill that guy
you know what I'm saying like that's
what all the articles are it's like you
know Amazon gives 100 million dollars to
this and it's just like yo don't kill me
is there not the difference between
something that's editorial and something
that's just a platform though like Bezos
can influence what goes out on the
Washington Post a lot more easily than
Elon can tell people what to tweet yeah
but Elon can also tweet whatever the
[ __ ] he wants and he can also never get
removed not only can it never get
removed but he can also remove [ __ ]
that's said about him that's fake
right he could be like that's fake news
he can't do that from The Washington
Post
they did that fact check thing didn't
they about uh
I'm not saying he would do this but he
can there's power yes you know you and
all news is on Twitter right now that's
what Twitter is it's really a news feed
right so the watching the post nobody
goes to the Washington Post to read an
article they see the article pop up on
Twitter and then they go to it so if
they're posting fake news about Elon he
could say yeah that's fake news adios
see you later they did that thing about
was it pensioners uh benefit checks and
it got fact checked by saying that the
reason that pensioners in the US are now
getting so much more money is because of
inflation and everything is adjusted for
inflation so the increase was massive
but the increase was based on the fact
that inflation is massive hilarious and
it was a whatever it's called a little
window below so they fact checked it
yeah and put it on the tweet and it was
like uh this is why this and it was
within like two days of Elon buying
Twitter it was [ __ ] hilarious I love
that did you see the new [ __ ] that just
came out today that the FBI the ex
Council to the FBI who was working for
Twitter got hold of the Twitter files
before they went to mataibi and uh the
other lady that was part of the Twitter
release and he it seems allegedly has
scrubbed the links between the FBI and
the hunt Biden laptop thing and he's now
been fired by Elon
you never stop working for the FBI
you think
once you're in you're in yeah you're
more effective being a retired FBI guy I
don't trust retired CIA I don't trust
retired FBI you think they're gonna let
you retire with all that information
you know what I mean it's like no this
is that's a lifetime job man if they
give you information they could shut the
whole thing down you're in for life and
you better know you're in for life it's
not like you do your 20 years and you
write your tell-all book we don't got
that many tell-all books right we got
the confessions of an economic Hitman he
just said the [ __ ] that we all know he
didn't really say anything and also he's
a scumbag for that don't like do it
profit off of doing it and then write a
book about how bad it is and then profit
off of that that's the liver King Arc
that's what's coming next which is what
that you go through the
villain and then I am now the hero that
is coming clean for whatever without
being honest that's who I am yeah and
then one of my friends is adamant that
his end goal is to become a WWE star
like that Alex asked him and he was like
we were like do you do wrestling he's
like oh I'm 45 and then he goes no no
like WWE so he actually thought that he
would like like be a wrestler yeah like
do some MMA [ __ ] yeah he was like nah
but uh I don't know if he's gonna do the
WWE maybe but yeah go do it and if that
was the whole goal then that would be
very deceptive yes I don't think that is
I think that I think that he he
genuinely
yeah I think he genuinely found
something that was very helpful to like
him and his family and he shared it and
monetized it and anytime you monetize
anything I'm going to be skeptical
like anytime there's money Associated I
told him I was like bro if you were an
accountant and you did this [ __ ] nobody
would question it no one would care
because you're not making any money off
it the second you make money off
something there's always a little bit of
a the incentives aren't going to be
quite as pure right yeah yeah man I mean
this is why heberman is such a [ __ ]
interesting example he's like what do
you suggest that I take for my fidojia
regressus or whatever [ __ ] supplement
it is and he just goes well I'm not
involved with any of these companies but
this is what I think and it gives you so
much Faith to what he's saying yeah is
genuinely what he believes yeah because
he has no incentive to say otherwise
like all that that guy sells I think is
maybe like ad-free access and t-shirts I
think he's gonna do some supplements or
he already eventually supplements
eventually he should do we should look
that up he might even have some now well
uh but he should because we trust him
right correct yeah but that's what
latent Leverage is right so
um imagine that you continue to give and
give and give and give to oh then it's
time to yeah to your audience and then
when they do they don't feel aggrieved
about buying [ __ ] from you 100 I think
that probably worked for me with the
special like I had given away so many
[ __ ] hours of stand-up comedy that
when I was finally like yo I really
believe in this thing this thing cost me
a lot of money
can you guys support me I think there
was a lot of people just DM me they're
like yo we'd be more than happy to thank
you like and that was really cool
because when you start giving away [ __ ]
for free so much you expect it to be
free in your head even though it's not
free for you to work out you know like I
put 15 years into this you know so I was
like but yeah that was a cool response
latent leverage latent leverage yeah you
just accumulate I mean it's garyvee's
like job job right hook philosophy it's
also like dating it's like dinner dinner
there it is speaking of dating monkey
pox yeah that's equal equal
opportunities in other news this episode
is brought to you by whoop it is the
best fitness tracker that I have ever
found it's the only one that I've ever
stuck with and it tracks absolutely
everything from my sleep to my recovery
even the workouts that I do every single
day through this strap which is on 24 7.
my resting heart rate my heart rate
variability and even how much I'm
breathing throughout the night tells me
my quality of sleep it gives me trends
and reports over time but the most
important thing is it actually nudges my
behavior through suggest questions in an
app it's a digital coach not just a
fitness tracker and it encourages me to
change my behavior that will improve my
health over the long term even better
than that you can join for free pay
nothing for the brand new whoop 4.0
strap and get your first month for free
so you buy it for free try it for free
and if you do not like it after 29 days
they'll give you your money back head to
join.woop.com Modern wisdom to sign up
right now that's
join.woop.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]